welcome back to behind the screens of
this week we're talking about thor
ragnarok yeah and I've got a special
exclusive extended scene just for you
guys with the Grand Master plus a
sit-down interview later in the show
with director Taika Waititi that goes
off the rails so why are we talking
about Thor in February well it's coming
home to the fans on digital blu-ray DVD
and with that comes deleted scenes
interviews and all kinds of goodies I
like most of you adored Jeff Goldblum's
Grand Master and wanted even more of him
so as a treat take a look at an extended
scene where Thor and the Grand Master
meet for the very first time well it's
not such a great great yeah I see you've
been familiarizing yourself with our our
obedience disk it's a little invention
of mine by the way you know some people
find it kind of an erotic walk with me
I'm gonna tell you something obedience
disk I've never been crazy about that
name I was supposed to be a placeholder
until I can think of something better
but everybody started to call him
obedience is what
guys guys here's what I want to know who
are you I didn't hear anything but
weren't there's like sparkles out of
your fingers like lightning maybe oh
good yeah there he is hey cuz we almost
couldn't find you already been hiding
hmm so admit what you did
Carlo what you said it was only a small
camels why did you do this small camels
gambling gambling I don't know what that
means gambling with the camel Oh Gaby
you just said it was camping there's no
so bad
Camping's bad but what you really do I
was gambling gatlings
Oh gambling is good Carlo I pardon you
do it again though right officially
officially pardoned from life I hope
there are just hours and hours of
deleted scenes of Jeff Goldblum plus a
full audio commentary let may be dreamy
sorry speaking of dreamy director Taika
Waititi is a gosh-darn delight and I got
to sit down with him to attempt to
seriously discuss the film but I kind of
knew that something like this would
happen
who do we have to talk to to get a like
a Korg in the porn short because
everyone is putting them together on the
Internet poor gand Korg film Korg saving
the Pogues from the jogs as we all know
the jogs favourite food
dogs on the planet snog Korg comes along
and it's like sort of it's like your
Jimbo
he comes along into the town of pogs
Portville and he basically is
single-handedly warts all the attacks of
the chalks and everyone then smog was
happily ever after House Beautiful
it's just taker he also pitched a full
rom-com with vision and Scarlet Witch
yeah that's up right now on e t--'s
YouTube page we'll drop a link in the
description to make it a little easier
but here's a sneak peek
are we smiling I'm like so how much cuz
I always it I'm always like busy with my
business yeah and I'm like that kind of
happy-go-lucky idiot
who will never settle down yeah never
get a job yes I'm so frustrating to be
around and you're the business business
business I'm like why don't you chill
out did you like to see that I kind of
would that's all for this week guys go
see Black Panther tonight yeah it's out
and let me know your thoughts our
spoiler free review is up right now I'll
also link that in the description just
make it easy let me know what you guys
want to see next week in the comments
and you can always chat with me on
Twitter calm the sea nest website in the
land until next time pork nation